if you could design an itinerary to take
Jordan on either like a dream vacation
or something to piss him off what would
it be if you could do that and way o to
piss Jordan off it would probably be one
of the things he does very strongly as
deny his heritage so I take him back to
his hometown in Long Island and I would
make him wear a sign that says i am
jordan shlonsky and i grew up here yeah
that's what I would do do we can grow as
human beings we can start one place
what's doing Lander online what is this
you know we've been moved as human
beings we can grow if you will I'm Bill
Curtis and this is American crime it's
not a question of denial yes I was there
and now I'm here so I'm not the credible
explanation I visit all right all right
very good hands back in pockets yeah oh
you're hoping a microphone is
unnecessary watch my bauble here watch
the way he moves the way he acts he
studied humans for a long time on his
planet and he came here to try and fool
us and he did a shitty shitty job
you